bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon aujourd'hui la défense sicilienne
bien entendu mais surtout la variante
chef d'un gang variante la plus tendue
de la cécilienne ouverte ou en tout cas
une des variantes les plus classiques et
pour analyser cette ouverture totalement
superbe j'ai avec moi stéphane laborde
bonjour stéphane bonjour et loi alors
comme c'est la première fois que tu
viens pour la c6 lainage dorff et bien
tu va déjà nous dire ce que tu en penses
de cette fameuse cécilienne d'âge d'or
sont très difficiles à jouer très
difficile à jouer parce que les noirs
manque des espaces quand même c'est pas
facile à trouver mais kasparov a
démontré que c'est l arme la plus
tranchante à son avis également fisher
et fisher aussi évidemment fischer casse
kasparov les deux champions du monde et
on peut noter que une des plus belles
parties qui ait jamais été joués c'est
une nécessité d'un âge d'or c'était une
partie entre fischer espace qui lors des
championnats du monde une rente du poids
une pio empoisonné par ailleurs que vous
avez vu avec jean louis cha banal à
l'ouverture un petit peu pour voir c'est
sedan prend b2 fantastique où les blancs
donnent un pion pour se retrouver avec
une très grosse attaque c'est la
variante la plus compliquée de la ccn
d'âge d'or c'est l'option empoisonné
bien entendu est également d'autres
partis mythique notamment la plus belle
partie durica sport fait jamais joué de
sa vie c'est la partie
karpov et kasparov 24e partie du match
quel sport fait obligés de gagner il est
noir c'est très tendu ambiance super
chaude à séville à séville et joue tour
sept ou huit manoeuvre destructrice
évidemment il ya beaucoup de grands
classiques dans cette défense n'a tort
la veille en chef d'un gang donc ça va
être tout de suite quoi dire de plus que
de vous montrer et bien exactement les
coûts constitutifs de cette variante
alors c'est pas la variante la plus à la
mode actuellement donc tout à fait tout
à fait mais elle est quand même
elle a quand même été extrêmement joué
notamment lors des matches karpov et
kasparov alors là exceptionnellement
l'échiquier tournée côté noir
tout simplement parce que nous vous
proposons de jouer la ccn âge d'or avec
les noirs et que donc on va prendre le
bon côté pour nous c'est normal il faut
tout de suite s'habituer à voir les
bonnes couleurs du bon côté eux quatre
ces cinq cavaliers f3 donc ça on l'a dit
la cécilienne ouverte stéphane ça
commence par qui veut dire que trois
quoi qu'il arrive puisque on va jouer
des 4 et échanger des pions moi c'est
probablement le couple
if d'autres coûts sont quand même moins
moins fort et permettent aux noirs de
s'en sortir assez facilement des six
tout ça pour les neiges d'offres c'est
le fameux coup souple des quatre pions
prend des quatre cavaliers prend des
quatre cavaliers f6 qu'elle et ses trois
à six donc si vous voulez des
commentaires sur ses couleurs vous allez
dans l'émission initiation à la neige
d'or et vous aurez tout ce qu'il vous
faut
assises c'est le coup stéphane qui
caractérise complètement se dépense âge
d'or moi tout à fait avec des idées
notamment de jouer b5 et surtout de
prendre la caste des 500 poches des
fonds de cinq échecs se cache un
cavalier d'aller sur cette case aussi ça
peut souvent être embêtant parce qu'on
veut souvent développées saddam sur la
casse et sept coups très utile et en
même temps coûte très très souple
puisqu'on n'a pas encore bougé le pion
eux on l'a pas mis en eau si ce niveau 5
et ça c'est avantageux pour quoi et bien
parce que le foot est vite contrôle
encore la case des caves
donc ça évite que les blancs puisse
pousser tout de suite
gedo g4 et commencer à venir taquiner
lecavalier 6 en jouant une attaque
d'options donc c'est un coup très souple
fou aux deux ça c'est un petit coup il
n'a pas l'air très très fort et les
blancs tout de suite annoncent leur
ambition de jouer avec le petit run away
ils veulent très vite joué petit rock et
l'idée c'est de jouer f2f 4 la poussée
du pion pour essayer de mettre sous
pression le centre en noir tout à fait
donc faux de ce n'est pas la variante la
plus tranchant mais c'est un des coups
qui débute la varende chef dingue on va
voir que là donc on peut jouer avec les
noirs soit 26,65 c'est-à-dire conception
et sont aussi souvent le 5 puisque la
ville et ont de l'avancé mais nous avons
choisi nous avons sélectionné pour vous
le coup de 7,6 et prenons le meilleur
donc là on arrive pour la première fois
stéphane dans la structure de pions dite
du petit centre petit centre
caractérisée par les deux pions aussi
cédé 6 qui contrôle très bien toutes les
cases devant f5 des 5,5 et c5 dont qui
empêche les blancs d'avancé plus ça fait
une espèce de murailles déjà donc les
noirs ont un avantage de structures
option puisqu'ils sont plus nombreux au
centre ils ont deux pions contre un seul
pour les blancs les idées dans ce petit
centre stéphane elles sont de plusieurs
ordres
on peut jouer soit avec eux 5 assez
souvent chasser le cavalier provoquer
une réaction soit avec des 5
donc de toutes façons les noirs ont
beaucoup trou soit ne pas bouger du tout
au centre c'est toutes les options alors
que les blancs eux leur plan d'attaqué
contre ce petit centre sont très connus
il faut qu'il joue avec le pion f en f4
il installe donc un duo de pions en 4 f4
ensuite ils jouent soit 11,5 soit f5 au
choix oui s'ils peuvent
voilà les deux plans d'attac communément
à nous mais les noirs eux quand ils ne
bougent pas leur centre ils menacent de
jouer avec b5 très souvent donc ici à
nantes se prémunit donc c'est une partie
d'exemple à un an contre kasparov
ce premier jour le coût à 2 à 4 c'est
très logique
cavet vc 6 donc là on a dit énormément
dans introduction à la nage dorff que
lecavalier on savait jamais trop s'il
fait le net on sait si ce qu'on 17
oui parce qu'en 17 souvent il peut aller
sur la case c5 faire pression sur le
pian 1,4 tout à fait donc c'est aussi un
plan intéressant mais ici le problème
stéphane dion mais le cavalier sur la
case 17
et bien tout simplement on n'a pas le
temps d'attaquer de 4 efficacement
puisque les blancs vont jouer avec f4 et
dès que le cavaliere en c5 qui aura eu
cinq et on va se faire attaquer très
très méchant donc il faut pas permettre
ça ajoutons qu'elle et ses 6 et on va
voir quel est le plan petit rock
biologique normal et des convois petit
rock quand on est en train de la
cécilienne il faut penser à une chose il
faut penser aux options de seydou bon
c'est quand chinois qui a mentionné ça
quand les blancs ne joue pas convaincre
le pion c2 est faible et toujours les
noirs auront énormément de jeux dessus
mais le contrôle de noir effectivement
se joue sur la colonne ces semi ouverte
on voit que cette colonne une tour peut
l'occuper efficacement effectivement
pilonné le pion ces deux voire parfois
se sacrifier contre le hac avait laissé
trois faire un sacrifice de qualité
c'est ça puisque quand on prend le cas
et c'est 3 bien on prend aussi le temps
aux quatre donc ça c'est plusieurs idées
fausses est tout à fait logique fouet 3
c'est normal petit rock et maintenant
les blancs jouent le coup f2f quatre
caractéristiques tout à fait ils veulent
justement faire des menaces soit avec f5
soit avec eux 5
pour l'instant le 5 n'est pas possible
puisque contrôlé par les noirs mais en
tout cas on sait jamais ça peut arriver
plus vite qu'on ne le pense
dan c7 faut calmer le jeu il faut
empêcher les noms de menacer un jour aux
4,5
voilà sept damas et sept contre ans le 5
derrière le pion des six
une bonne possibilité de contre attaque
et en plus ça sort de la colonne des sas
est un thème important aussi parce que
les blancs vont être amené e à occuper
la colonne semi-ouverte des avec une
tour est menacée ou 4,5 donc la dame a
intérêt à sortir de cette colonne et en
plus stéphane sa connecte les taux enfin
pas tout de suite mais ça a tendance à
permettre mais nous aurons de se
connecter une connexion tour ce qui est
toujours une bonne chose on est objectif
de l'ouverture et après le 11e coup des
blancs wash alors ça c'est un combat
sérieux au rachat alors pourquoi ce coup
de petits ce petit coup de roanne à la
fois mystérieux oui et non alors on va
expliquer pourquoi dans ce genre de
position les noirs ont une menace
directe
ils menacent de jouer kevin prend des
quatre fous prend des quatre le pion
avance sur la case aux 5
on va montrer par exemple sur un coup
comme h2 h3 qui ne sert à rien par
exemple ça c'est un exemple on prendrait
en d4 fou prend des 4 au 5 donc en toute
logique pions prend aux cinq moyens pour
être prendre ou reculer le fou ont
reculé fou ça amènera une autre un autre
type de position qui dérape position
tout à fait pion prend fouet 3 et
maintenant les noirs pourra jouer ou c5
est chargé mais feront échangeant les
foot et aux cases noires et ça c'est
très important pour eux oui parce que le
fouet deux se retrouvent être en mauvais
fou maintenant puisqu'ils tablent sur le
pion aux quatre exactement là il va
avoir du mal à trouver des bonnes geoana
et dans ce genre de position les blancs
aimerait bien de temps en temps pouvoir
je me fous g5 ou alors pouvoir quitter
la diagonale avec le fou mais là peuvent
pas mais là ils peuvent pas puisqu'ils
sont cloués donc de toutes façons le
courroux à agen a sa logique
ça évite la menace des noirs qui est de
prendre des cats et deux jours de cinq
voix là et ça évite d'ultérieures échec
imaginons sous le fouet trois quitte sa
diagonale un coup comme d'hab et si
d'emblée six échecs prendrait le plan b
2 - là tout à fait donc c'est un coup de
sécurité qui très classique extrêmement
jouer et qui nous amène à notre position
les noirs ici doivent choisir un ou le
coup qu'on vous conseille ses tours 8
où effectivement cette fois-ci stéphane
très très mystérieux mais comme on a vu
dans beaucoup beaucoup de cas les noirs
jouent avec le 5
hélas la tour en huit trous un poste
très intéressant puisqu'elle va taper
sur le clou 4 après l'ouverture après
les changes de quelques pièces dans
cette position donc nous sommes au 11e
où les noirs viennent de jouer tour vite
il ya beaucoup d'entre deux coups qui
amène à cette position c'est vraiment
ici d'aaland celle venant
mondy tout à fait alors là les blancs
plusieurs possibilités notamment il ya
des plans base de dames 1
c'est d'amener la dame sur la 4g 3
essayer de monter une attaque contre le
roi noir quand les dames et angers trop
aux menaces aux cinq aux menaces aussi
aux cinq essais pour soutenir avancé de
4 5 et parfois je crois que les blancs
jouent aussi fou et ce trois fois f3c le
coût principal
ça c'est un coût qui n'est pas un coup
d' attaque mais un coup d'anticipation
du développement des noirs sadi au noir
et bien vas-y développe toi maintenant
si tu peux le faire en tout cas tu vas
avoir du mal à bouger ton pions by pass
moine fou s'est mis dans cette grande
diagonale
donc il ya plusieurs coups il ya des
mains pour venir en g3 et jouer avec 2,5
là on vous annonce les plans des blancs
parce que c'est ceux contre lesquels
vous aux réalités fouet 3 qui est un
coup pour vous dire comment vous
développer il ya également le ku'damm d2
qui est un coup que je n'ai pas compris
qui est un coût de développement naturel
mais qui est difficile à expliquer
puisqu'on ne voit pas vraiment walid et
des blancs enfin on va quand même le
commenter dernier coup c'est fou j'ai un
qui est un coup curieux et qui permettra
justement de voir exactement comment les
noirs doivent réagir si les blancs ne
font rien alors là c'est un homme
qu'elle est blanc contre kasparov et
choisit le coup mais je choisis le ponam
d2 mystérieux d'une des deux assez
mystérieux et parce que là ça fait rien
contre l'attack de rock ça fait rien
pour contrôler le centre est par contre
salies les tours c'est lille et tours
c'est davantage très clairement les
tours sont maintenant interconnectés on
va remettre la touran par exemple sur la
case de 1 ou sur la case d1 voilà tout à
fait donc c'est un coût de développement
mais il est très difficile pour les
plans d'attaqué ce sont aussi ces
instructions des six parce qu'il est
très très bien défendue par le fawcett
qui ne risque pas de quitter son poste
donc ça c'est une remarque donc dam des
deux camps vous ne comprenez pas bien
vous jouez un coup naturel fou 17 qu'on
ne développe pas normal l'idée de ce fou
fou 17 salit les tours sacre otage de
paris cécile ça protège lequel celle-ci
c'est-à-dire qu'on reprend avec le fou
en 7 6
le prochain coup ça peut être tour à des
8 si les blancs ne font rien de très
menaçant on envisage également de jouer
qu'elle prend des 4 es fou c'est 6 donc
ça c'est également une possibilité même
des deux n'est pas un coup très
dangereux ça ne me fait rien on peut
tout simplement se contenter que le foot
et 7 pourra dès maintenant il termine
son développement mais sa tour sur la
colonne semi ouverte et on l'a vu il va
avoir du mal à créer dès maintenant
sur le plan des six d'autant plus que
garry kasparov dans cette position
jouent tour à des mythes et maintenant
que fait wichmann internats non des
biens c'est très difficile à dire
puisque on ne voit pas comment il peut
améliorer la force de ses pièces c'est à
dire que s'il joue un coup comme g4 qui
on verrait d'un coup thématiques avec
l'idée de jouer g5 et bien ce moment-là
garry kasparov et d'appréhender 4 et
surtout prend et bien il joue ses six
libérant la caisse 17 pour le cavalier
ou même cinq ou même 5 5 qui conclue
entre attaques sur le plan on peut voir
cette variante d'ailleurs imaginer le g4
keller prématuré pouvant rapidement que
cavalli prend des quatre faut prendre
les quatre ou cinq a l'air fort puisque
ça attaque le fou et en même temps le
fils pions g4 à l'air perdu oui tout à
fait ce qui est fou et cavani attaque
c'est le genre de position dont il faut
se méfier stéphane puisque même quand on
la culture g4 on est encore exposés à de
l' attaque mais ici tout simplement
donc là vous vérifierez par vous même
comment ça se passe mais a priori das a
l'air plutôt bien pour les noirs donc
ici après tour à des beats hannon
d'afrique a et b 3 et là on va vous
montrer juste un seul coup pour les
noirs dans cette position posez vous la
question qu'est ce que je vais faire
maintenant
et là il faut comprendre que le problème
c'est ce fou 17 qu'on a envie de le
mettre sur la grande diagonale mais
qu'on a pas envie de dépasser dans
lequel et c6 donc pour ça vous trouvez
le coup fou c'est vite la menace c b6
est fou bessette et une fois que les
noirs ont mille fois sur la grande
diagonale dans une structure de petits
centres et bien ils n'ont plus du tout à
s'inquiéter donc là la partie a continué
le show f3b six dames f2 à la ronde
il tente tout de suite une attaque
directe attaque alors ça c'est dangereux
puisque ça attaque nocturne b6 et c rama
yade attendait sarah marshall tourne à 8
derrière mais s'il ya eu tout simplement
qu'elle les 17 et la position s'est
simplifié très vite puisque après
qu'elle ait des cats ou bessette
les noirs ont achevé leur développement
les blancs n'ont strictement rien fait
dans cette position il n'y a pas d'
attaque particulière donc là vous avez
une très bonne position
on va maintenant stéphane passé à notre
deuxième exemple way qui est donc la
partie talent kasparov
on va arriver directement à la position
qui nous intéresse c'est à dire cette
variante cheikh m'bengue proprement dit
oula à nantes avait joué dam des deux
coups qu'on n'avait pas compris un an
j'avais joué dam des deux ici le coup de
talent beaucoup plus intéressant c'est
le coût d'un me voilà qu'à l'air de rien
c'est un petit coup de dames intéressant
parce qu'en fait on veut traverser
transféré par dont la dame sur la case
g3 menaçant e5
oui oui menaçant aussi le roi noir
menaçant la semble peut-être f5 et
flashy solstice attaquants on assemble
des choses
donc là il faut réagir tout de suite il
ya une vente précise il faut la
connaître tout simplement on prend en d4
fou prend aux 5,1 réaction totalement
thématiques dans l'iphone
si le foot doit partir si le fou vient
par exemple sur la 4g 1 on prend un f4
la tour prend et on joue faux 6 on verra
ça sera le thème d'une partie qui
viendra après et la très très bonne
position sur progrès saric puis on prend
1,5
s'il faut s'en va c'est toujours pareil
on a encore poussé 5 way qui va être pas
mal
ou alors faut aussi ce bref on a une
position normale
l'idée du coude a besoin c'est de jouer
dans cette version dames g3 pas mal
parce que le pian 1,5 et cloud et si on
s'inquiète loué il peut pas prendre le
fou parce que la dame sur l'emprise si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur le floch
d'ailleurs vous allez dans le tableau de
diagonale de son vous cliquez sur
techniques et stratégies les bases
eliane de sont spécialement dédiés au
cloud âge donc ici c'est un clouage de
base le pion aux cinq écrouées et
attaquer autre problème stéphane on a
tous à y plonger 7
ouais donc le cavadee m6 se retrouve
également au paysage sans chasser le
loup s'en va donc s'il le faut bien à un
fuite ou si le fou vend ses 5
oui c'est une erreur puisque dans ce cas
là il y aura tour problème si ce qui
finira tout à fait donc on se fout des
beats force et donc maintenant la dame
et protéger nos rites les noirs menace
de prendre le fou et la tour e 8 protège
depuis un an le 5 et le food et 8
continue de protéger le kayak 6 donc
c'est un coup idéal coup tout à fait
tout à fait bien pas idéal stephen parce
qu'ils les patrons en train de
construire
mais techniquement totalement juste fou
et 3 les blancs sont obligés de partir
vous aussi ce important de juifs ou aux
six maintenant parce que les blancs
pouvaient menacer cavaliers des 5 quel
dessein attaquant la dame qui était pas
forcément très agréable
tours a des seins et là on se décourage
suite et maintenant qu'est ce qui
s'passe sûr qu'il y ait des 5 et bien
c'est fait non je vous prends des
simples et sûres tu reprends ta dernière
prend l'option ces deux ouais ce fameux
fiancé 2 on en a déjà parlé
ici talent chauffe ou g5 ils menacent
donc éventuellement de prendre un f6 il
après la reprise du fou jouer fou et
deux sur la 4g 4 qui échangent encore
les fougasses blanchet qui cette fois-ci
s'installera en d5
donc ça c'est l'idée thématique de des
blancs ouais mais la casa sports vous
calé j'ai vite et pas de problème mais
reithalle revient kasparov revient et
répétition des compétitions donc ce coup
finalement damien n'est pas très
dangereux il faut réagir très
précisément partie aval et prend des
cavaliers prend fou prend de 5.5
correction classique
voilà donc les glandes perdu un petit
peu un tas engendre un peu inquiets
quand même un courant pas ça me fout un
peu lent oui et ça permet au noir de
justifier le fait d'avoir joué le pire
en noir d'un fois aux 6es et 5es
exactement exactement d'autant plus que
ce qu au 6 e 5 est très naturel
puisqu'il permet de développer le fou
s'est vite qui est toujours un de nos
problèmes de développement parties
suivantes stéphane marty suivante
voilà la partie me roesch niché aux
comptes regroupe les skis alors là c'est
un essai tout à fait curieux on va
revenir un petit peu en avance c'est
dans cette position là hop
si les noirs si les blancs essayer de
jouer le coup à 5,1 et cernes fixer des
pions noirs avant que kevin soir yves
mansat cependant empêcher définitivement
les noirs d'avoir des idées de jouer b6
ou des 5 pour mettre leurs fours sur la
case baisse est tout à fait donc là dans
cette position au touquet laissé six
attaques le pion à 5 1 à 5
quel et b3 c'est l'idée maintenant la
menace c'est fou à trois et on vient
s'installer sur les cases v6 avec
cavalli à 4 également ans à la fin ça a
l'air très fort mais donc on joue b5
tout simplement les cinq maintenant si
les blancs ne prennent pas en passant
est bien menaces békaa traîtrise du pian
2 4 prises en passant obligatoire d'aprr
en échec au roi et chaque endroit d'où
l'intérêt d'avoir joué trois chiens
avant oui un ces cas là on peut pas et
issifou bessette développement terminé
alors salaires idéal pour les noirs
parce que
les blancs peuvent plus je me fous de 3
soit la dame contrôler la case et ils
ont réussi à mettre leurs fous sur la
case baisse est tout à fait maintenant
les plans ça va être très très simple on
va jouer qu'à elle et des quatre
attaques l'option ces deux on va me
menacer on va centraliser nos tours on
va jouer tour a fuité tour des huit
uturbey huit tours des mythes on a
beaucoup de cases ici donc tout
simplement pour expliquer que ce coût à
5 n'est pas dangereux puisqu'on vous
cueille ses six attaques le pion
kébé 3 et des 5 donc c'est un tout petit
exemple juste pour dire que bon il faut
faire attention quand même mais ce
n'était pas un vrai danger
nouvel exemple à nantes entre kasparov
une autre partie position de base donc
on se rappelle que la nand avait déjà
joué dam des deux que talent avait tenté
dames 1 ouais mais ici à nantes joue le
coup le plus classique dans cette
pression c'est le couffo f3 phase iii
avec l'idée de mettre la pression sur
toutes les pièces là qui sont sur la
diagonale et le carré lisse et 6 le fou
le plan b 7 et la torah 8 exactement lé
avantages de ce coup fait froid c'est
que stéphane dans cette pression les
noirs ne peuvent pas jouer b6 ça serait
une grosse faute qui perdrait très très
vite a fait avaler procès ça perd trop
de matériel d'un prompt et e55 y adhérer
couvert points et l'enfilade et attaque
le carif si ces attaques le quai venir
pas répondre par des cinq qui fermerait
la diagonale on peut jouer qu'à l'un des
cinq médias qui avaient les rangs des
cinq qui on prend et fou prend des cinq
quarts mais cela pour les problèmes sont
intactes donc après x 3 on ne peut pas
jouer ce coup b6 c'est pas faut pas se
tromper il faut pas se tromper
comment faut-il jouer c'est une question
qu'on peut se poser donc il ya eu tourbe
et 8 qui a été joué les noirs ne sachant
pas trop quoi faire
mais la vérité est ailleurs il faut
jouer dans cette position fou 17 la
menace donc c'est une fois de plus
cavani prompt fou prend et aux cinq
puisque le fou vient d'annoncer 6 très
avantageusement donc sur n'importe quel
coût de dames on prend des quatre on
joue au 5 et ensuite on jouera avec
pouces et 6 il faut contrôler la caste
des 5 avec le fou c'est très très
important
donc ça c'est le principe de base dans
cette position très logique qu'avec des
3l et b3 ça évite la menace justement
qui était qualif en québec ça peut
menacer à 5
ça peut menacer à sinsat peut menacer à
5 puisque à 5 ça fixe les pions noirs et
les fauves et 6 vient qui est très fort
poule b si ce qui arrive
ça serait pas une très bonne nouvelle
donc dans cette position on joue le
groupe des six pour empêcher à 5 pour
empêcher à 5
maintenant les blancs toujours ils
peuvent rien faire s'il ne joue qu'avec
les pièces donc ils sont obligé
d'arriver au plan critique le plan qui
doit vous faire peur c'est l'avancée du
pion j'ai donc il joue g4 d'autant plus
que ici la benâte jestin qui est très
forte puisque ça gagne une pièce voilà
et alors c'est moins s'est moins
affaibli sans que qu'on l'a vu tout à
l'heure puisque maintenant le flou est
roi et la dame d un protège bien g4 et
en plus le fos 3 pour revenir en g2
éventuellement trop bien protégé son
droit
donc les blancs ce fait glisser un peu
le rock mais pas trop d'autant plus que
la dernière fois stéphane il y avait eu
cinq qui attaquaient le cahier des
carmes là c'est pas possible ça
n'attaque pas et donc je sens que perdre
très vite après f5 fitch et 500 kg c'est
n'y avait que deux pilotes très forts
donc là il faut avoir les nerfs solides
donc je vous fous ces huit dans cette
position maintenant c'est possible
puisque et plus cavalli processes donc
on est revenu dans la position d'avant
ont effectivement perdu de temps mais
l'idée et stéphane c'est qu'on va
compléter de développement avec le fond
mais cette très important et en même
temps va rapatrier le kavé sur la case
17 mois ça libère une case pour le
cavalier donc j'ai 5 voilà qu'elle est
décédée à la célèbre comprend le coût
foncier vite
le cavalier pour revenir sur la case des
sept fous j'ai deux pour passer la dame
en attaque où est passée la dame en
attaque c'est finalement ça libère aussi
la tour eiffe un voyage qui prend le
contrôle viennent maintenant le pion f4
et peut menacer f5 fou bessette les
noirs ils ont complété leur
développement maintenant il faut juste
ne pas se ferme était alors là faut
faire attention pour les blancs les
blancs pourrait jouer vouloir jouer f5
mais ça ça va faiblir le roi blanc c'est
à dire que la sur f5
on peut supposer que les noirs prendrait
un f5 probablement peut-être et jouer
ensuite car elle lisse et 601 5 à leurs
problèmes sans que ces problématiques
stéphane puisqu'il y avait laissé cinq
ans un charisme et en revanche la
réaction normale sur le coup f5 c'est de
jouer cavalier 17 sur la case au sein on
n'a pas peur d'eux f6 puisque yapo en
fuite
donc voilà comment on réagit sur cinq
c'est à dire que le coup et cinq est un
énorme affaiblissement puisque ça donne
complètement la case aux cinq au noir
donc en général on n'est pas tout à fait
chaud pour le jouer avec les mains
damages 5 menace très simple tous rêvent
trois tours h3 et mat
donc ici il faut réagir enfin quel et b4
pour l'instant on contre attaque
champions c'est 2 way tour f2 donc son
rêve deux doigts mais alors si on joue
ton rêve 2 évidemment on abandonne
l'idée torres 3 à 3 3 oui tout à fait
mais surtout à droite de toute façon en
fait il y avait g6 qui est joué quand
même ici puisque c'est le plan de
défense
damas 3 est maintenant un plan
thématique fois fluide donc j'ai six est
un excellent coup de défense dès que
vous êtes attaqué il faut jouer g6
repasser le fou éventuellement angers7
avec une position solide ce fou n'est
pas là pour aller prendre en c3 on veut
pas faire cette menace leurs mots justes
consolider la position autour de nos
trois dans cette position dès que les
bourgeois kf5 on jouera cavignaux 5 et
on va tenir là on est évidemment
stéphane dans la position la plus
compliquée qui existent de cette vente
chez belin ouais c'est celle où les
bleus ont poussé tous leurs pions ils
ont défendu ce côté là avec leurs pièces
et donc qu'ils obtiennent une à des
perspectives d' attaque assez forte
là il faut avoir les nerfs solides et
c'est dans ce genre de position que
kasparov avait joué contre karpov tour
cette suite ou 8 et ensuite percé le 5
avec l'ouverture des lignes très
compliqué donc voilà on va revoir cette
variante tranquillement roi h1 tours 8
ça c'est le début fouet f3 le coup le
plus dangereux
il faudrait fou 17 on ne peut pas jouer
v6 à cause de quelques pensées site et
sur calais b 3 puisque ont menacé de
prendre des cats et 2,5
on joue des six avec l'idée de repasser
le fousseret et s17 g4 fou s'est vite
j'ai syndic qui a aidé cette fougue et
deux pour passer la dame fou bessette on
a terminé le développement maintenant il
faut se défendre
damages 5 bonjour québec a tracé
kasparov il a tout calculé tour f2 g6
damas trois fois fuite
la position devient extrêmement
compliqué évidemment c'est très
difficile
dernière partie dernier exemple c'est
cette partie
c'est une partie de moi en fait que j'ai
joué donc à pékin contre 1
maître chinois youtube shouting donc
dans cette partie évidemment j'ai joué
ce que je vous conseille donc trop vite
il a joué fou j'ai un wake ou
apparemment anodin on se demande un
petit peu ce qu'il veut faire et là la
bonne réponse c'est de jouer qu'à mêlée
prend des 4 donc ça oblige le foire en
jouer encore une fois alors là il a pris
de la dame
s'ils prennent du fou c'était pareil
ouais tu apprends des 4 e 5
donc ça tout à fait normal ce qui est
très important quand on affaiblit à t5
c'est d'être sûr de pouvoir le jouer il
faut aussi toutefois aussi c'est de
prendre des 5 avec le jeu dam des trois
pions pour un f4 donc là s'il fait qu'il
y ait des 5
j'échange en d5 on n'y a pas de problème
puisque j'ai un focus déjà donc
tourcoing f4 faut 6 et là quand vous
avez cette structure donc faut aussi
s'est qualifiée ce qui défendent la
caisse des 5
vous n'êtes pas en danger surtout que
dès que le cas libyen là on le prend
avec le font donc ensuite ça va
torah et fin oui parce que sa bouche la
taxe sur le plan des six exactement
hélas le dernier petit coup ses
cavaliers 17 coups tranquille sûr qu'il
ait des cinq on prend toujours il peut
pas reprendre de la dame comme il le
voudrait puisque l'option ses doigts est
en prise aux menaces de jouer cavalier
ou cinq qui attaquent adam et qui va
défendre le curé vii très bien et
ensuite on va jouer avec g6 où elle fit
donc ça tout ça ça c'est vraiment la
position de base élémentaire que vous
devez connaître toujours il faut
vérifier donc
par exemple après coup j'ai un cavalier
prend des 4 e 5 échange des pions et
fois au cices voilà ça c'est vraiment la
manoeuvre que qui doit devenir chez vous
une seconde nature
on prend qu'il prend delà de la dame ou
du foot c'est un réflexe de la na waie
exactement eu cinq dames rouge surprend
f4 tour prend 1,4 faut 6 et ensuite qui
a aidé cette vidéo 5g six fours et fuite
tout ça ça doit se développer
naturellement donc cette fois je crois
qu'on a fait à peu près le tour de cette
défense yens dingue
ouais ouais on avait les plus grandes
lignes le plus intéressante c'est
surtout cette variante avec france 3
qu'elle peut dans chose tout à fait
c'est la variante choisie par allende à
noter que kasparov n'a jamais perdu dans
cette position ou en tout cas sauf une
fois contre sokolov mais c'était extrême
il a fait une gaffe
alors qu'il était gagnant donc la
position est saine puisque quatre
porsche n'a jamais perdu
ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas de problème
soyez en confiance et entraînez-vous
éventuellement vous pouvez essayer la
position de base
on vous l'a déjà montré ses selles après
tours 8 beau coup d'essai pour les
blancs beaucoup de réponses pour les
noirs c'est vraiment thématique donc
position à jouer en fellinien on peut
dire en famille voilà on vous remercie
d'avoir suivi cette émission merci
stéphane d'être revenu donner un petit
coup de main ouais je suis toujours là
toujours là et donc on vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour toujours
la défense night of thème qui vous sera
communiquée très prochainement versée
e